-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching.
What a show we have for you
tonight.
Hailey Bieber is here tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
tWitch is here tonight.
We have music from
Phoebe Bridgers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
From the new movie "Elvis" --
and let me tell you something.
This kid is unbelievable.
Put your money on this guy, man.
Oh, my gosh.
Austin Butler is here tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is right.
Elvis is in the building
tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Speaking of movies, everyone's
talking about this today.
I don't know if you saw.
It was all over the place.
Warner Bros. released the first
picture of Ryan Gosling as Ken
in the upcoming "Barbie" movie.
This is real.
Here's the picture.
This is real. Here he is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's also what comes up
when you Google
"sexy Guy Fieri Halloween
costume."
Just saying.
[ Laughter ]
Can we see it again?
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It looks like Draco Malfoy if he
went to Barry's Bootcamp.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's right.
He's the total package.
Well, minus the package.
[ Laughter ]
It's Ken. It's Ken.
It's a Ken joke.
Smooth.
-Let's get to some news here,
everyone.
I read that Dr. Fauci has tested
positive for COVID.
But luckily, he's only
experiencing mild symptoms.
Yeah, yeah.
COVID must feel like
it just reached
the final boss in a video game.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Yo, we did it.
We did it.
We got -- We beat Fauci."
That's right.
Dr. Fauci has COVID.
Right now, even he's reading
the CDC guidelines like,
"Damn, these are confusing."
[ Laughter ]
"Isolate for five days
then quarantine.
What do I do?"
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys hear about this?
Amid a salmonella outbreak,
the CDC has instructed people
not to kiss or snuggle
their chickens.
[ Laughter ]
Although, if you're kissing
and snuggling chickens,
I'm not sure salmonella
is your biggest issue.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Eggs.
-When the news broke,
Dr. Fauci was like,
"Well, my day just keeps getting
worse and worse."
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this. I heard that
since taking office,
President Biden has seen
his approval rating drop
the most among young voters.
Yeah, well, I think he's trying
to win young voters back.
Check out this new ad
the White House just released.
-What's up, fam?
You know who's got you?
The only president who's
straight up bussin'.
Joe Biden.
President B is clapping back
on the haters with --
-Sensible bipartisan policies.
-We ain't trying to simp.
We're just spilling the tea.
Because we've got BPE.
-Big president energy.
-So support Joe Biden today
because our White House daddy
is about to go goblin mode
on inflation.
[ Goat screams ]
-This ad was paid for by
a group of 50-year-old men
who just found out about
Urban Dictionary.
-There you go.
It's doing very --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Goblin mode.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Hey, guys.
I don't know if you heard this.
Molson Coors is pulling Coors
Light and Keystone Light from
stores after a viral video
showed cans
filled with a thick liquid.
[ Audience groans ]
Yeah, some stores returned them
while others just relabeled them
Guinness.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know about you,
but I like a beer
that you can eat
with a honey dripper.
[ Laughter ]
Well, today, after 27 years,
Microsoft officially shut down
Internet Explorer.
[ Audience awws ]
Yeah, you could tell
it was getting old
'cause there were errors
like this coming up.
First, "Error 404:
can't find my glasses.
Oh, wait, they're on my head."
[ Laughter ]
Look at this error.
"Error: Internet Explorer
stopped working.
Now it collect Civil War
medallions."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-You can tell it's getting old.
Look at this.
Finally, this error says,
"Error: Internet Explorer
is busy buying
a reverse mortgage
from Tom Selleck."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Maybe it's good that
they shut it down.
Well, guys, I just saw a new
design for airplane seats.
And I'm not sure
how I feel about it.
Take a look at this.
-It's called double-decker
seating.
This is the design.
It fits two levels of seats
inside a normal airplane.
So your legs go straight out
in front of you
with someone basically
sitting above them.
[ Laughter ]
-COVID or not,
if you're on the bottom,
you're going to want
to wear a mask.
[ Laughter ]
I just think -- I just think --
-Odor.
-It's going to be fun when
the flight attendant's like,
"Tonight's in-flight snack
is whatever the guy
above you is eating."
[ Laughter ]
Cheez-Its. Cheez-Its.
And finally, I know a lot of
people find math boring.
Well, that's why we've updated
math to make the equations
about stuff
that you can relate to.
It's time for
"Popular Mathematics."
♪♪
-♪ Popular mathematics ♪
♪ Mathematics ♪
-Let's take a look at
our first equation here.
If you take clogs
plus a hole punch
equals Crocs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Popular mathematics.
-Very popular.
-So, if you take Bill Clinton
plus nothing to do
plus a heat wave plus 100
equals the Billboard Hot 100.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow. Bill Bored. Hot 100.
-If you take The Penguin...
-Right.
-...plus six pints of Guinness,
it equals the Boston Celtics
mascot.
[ Laughter and applause ]
How about this one?
Here's a "kiss the chef" apron
plus a complaint to HR
equals "firm handshake the chef"
apron.
[ Laughter and applause ]
If you take Cheetos
plus Chachi...
-Uh-oh.
-...plus chicken plus euphoria
it equals Ch-Ch-Ch-Chia.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, if you take
a Twinkie plus googly eyes
plus $4 billion,
it equals the Minions franchise.
There you have it.
That's all the time we have
for "Popular Mathematics."